Today to updates and to vote for you
first. I suggested it in the last video,
but I'm announcing it here. Yes,
we're going on an animated journey
through the history of writing.
It'll be fun and honest to the concepts,
but it may take its share of historical
liberties to put you into the role of
the main character.
I'm hoping that the resulting videos will
be watchable back to back as a single
story. Tune in to see how
it all pans out. Second,
a conundrum for some of you.
The very first time we met was an
animated wonderment and then down the line
maybe that suggested older
videos with me lecturing at you.
Other people came in the other
way, looking for good information.
Dumping then got puzzled at me
wandering through a land of linguistic
curiosities.
This setting up of expectations in
marketing gets called a brand promise.
What I'm worried about is that this
disconnect leaves some of you disoriented.
It's like a broken brand promise.
I don't have a solution for this yet
other than making you aware of this change
over time and refreshing old thumbnails
to make those old videos look more like
a backup library of
resources for us to draw on.
So it's a very matchmaker
that brings us together.
Also stacks me up against other channels,
partly based on how many of my
videos you watch in a single sitting.
This discontinuity in your viewing
experience can hurt me too.
Speaking of your viewing experience,
which day of the week would
you most like to see me?
A blow new videos still Friday
or Tuesday or a different day?
Click to vote for your favorite
day and stick around for language.